this video is sponsored by audible who
are offering a free audiobook if you
sign up for a trial at audible.com slash
ASX if you haven't read The Game of
Thrones books before or you want to
reread you've got to try listening to
the audiobook it's a totally different
way to experience the story audible is
offering the first book of Thrones or
any other audio book for free and even
if you cancel your trial you can keep
the book so please sign up at the link
below you get a free book and it'll
really help out this channel thanks in
season 6 of The Game of Thrones show
Olenna Tyrell wonders if Cersei is the
worst person she's ever met Cersei does
do a lot of terrible things while the
wife of King Robert she has a secret
incestuous relationship with her twin
brother Jaime passing off their
illegitimate kids as Roberts rightful
heirs undermining the political system
of Westeros and leading to war when I
astark tangles with Cersei song Joffrey
Cersei has the innocent direwolf lady
executed and tries to get iya maimed or
killed
Cersei kills King Robert by getting him
drunk during a hunt then she ignores the
Kings will to have Ned Stark serve as
regent and instead has Ned imprisoned
that's all in book one in book two
Cersei has Roberts baby bastard bearer
murdered along with her mother
Cersei has an innocent woman Aleya rose
in the show brutally beaten in attempt
to hurt Circe's brother Tyrion she may
also be responsible for so Mandans
attempt on Tyrians life in book 3 Cersei
wrongfully accuses Tyrion of killing
Joffrey which gets Tyrion sentenced to
death in book 4 says he really goes to
town she has the High Septon killed as
some innocent Dwarfs killed has some
innocent guards killed and tries to have
Bronn and trystane Martell and Jon Snow
killed she just loves killing she also
sends a bunch of women to Qyburn to be
used in horrific experiments and
brutally tortures an innocent bard
she tries to frame Margaery Tyrell and
others for crime so they didn't commit
and makes a bunch of bad political
decisions she stops paying the Crown's
debts gives an expensive fleet of ships
to an unqualified pretty boy who steals
them and becomes a pirate and she lets
the faith militant
on themselves leading to the rise of the
high Sparrow
after this fasten disaster Circe's
crimes catch up with her she is
imprisoned by the faith and takes a walk
of shame that's as far as the books go
so far but in season six of the show
Searcy wreaks revenge she blows up the
sparrows and Tyrells with wildfire and
crowns herself queen of Westeros in her
final form as a sort of Maleficent Evil
Queen type so so she kind of is the
worst she hurts and kills innocent
people destabilize of the country and
contributes to war should we call her a
villain a monster if she just cruel and
selfish and stupid a vile evil [ __ ] in
Marjorie's words or could there be more
to Cersei Lannister in the first three
books of Thrones we only see Cersei
through the eyes of other characters but
starting in the fourth book we get
chapters from Circe's point of view we
read her thoughts and feelings her hopes
and dreams her past and glimpses of her
future so we can start to understand and
maybe sympathize with this complex
character we can even predict how Cersei
might die her story basically comes down
to three main themes power love and
prophecy the first line of Circe's first
chapter says she dreams of setting the
Iron Throne
high above them all so he wants to rule
she lusts for power with every waking
breath and it's a particular kind of
power that she wants people like Stannis
and Robb a Baratheon and Robb Stark have
power that you can see they wear crowns
and swing swords and lead armies and
everyone knows that they are in charge
in contrast people like Varys and
Littlefinger and Elena have a more
subtle kind of power they don't wear
crowns or swing swords or lead armies
instead they have secret spies and
schemes their influence is invisible but
very significant the Varys runs a
conspiracy Littlefinger causes war and
Elena kills King Joffrey and grows the
power of
without anyone even knowing it these
three are some of the most powerful
people in Westeros but Cersei isn't
interested in this subtle kind of power
in the show Littlefinger tell Cersei
that knowledge is power but then Cersei
demonstrates in her words that power is
power she doesn't want to influence
events from the shadows she wants people
to know that she's in charge she wants
to sit the throne and for great Lords
and proud ladies to kneel before her
these ideas about visible power and
pride are at the core of Circe's
personality and they seem to have mostly
come from Sosa's father Tywin Tywin was
Circe's only parent growing up after a
mother Johanna died giving birth to
Tyrion and Tywin is obsessed with family
legacy with Lannister power and pride he
says we must demonstrate the power of
Casterly Rock for all the realm to see
these ideas had a big impact on Cersei
she often thinks on the lessons Thailand
taught her and after Thailand is killed
by Tyrion Cersei thinks of herself as
Thailand's heir she wants to be seen as
the inheritor of his legacy and she
tries to act as he would thing is Tywin
was brutal he was responsible for some
of the worst atrocities in Westeros the
extermination of the rains of castamere
the sack of King's Landing claw gains
raids in the Riverlands the red wedding
not to mention his cruel treatment of
Tyrion and Teicher and others the
lessons Tywin taught are barbaric stuff
like never wound a foe when you can kill
him and the only way to keep your people
loyal is to make them fear you that
people are tools to be used and that
love is worthless
Cersei follows Thailand's cruel example
and in some of her darkest moments like
when she torches an innocent bard or
thinks about wiping out all the Ironborn
she tells herself that these things are
okay because it's what Tywin would have
done so a lot of Circe's brutality in a
pursuit of power and pride comes from
the lessons Tywin taught her but there's
a deeper conflict behind all this so she
thinks of herself as Thailand's only
true son as Lord Tywin with
the tension here because Cersei
Lannister is a woman there are powerful
women in Westeros look at Alina Tyrell
Asha Catelyn
Sansa Eyre Daenerys Visenya and Rainey's
but Westeros is a patriarchal medieval
Society which means unless you've got
dragons women usually aren't allowed to
hold direct power in their own right
some women hold soft lagoons of power
like a laner
but Cersei isn't allowed to be powerful
in the direct visible way that Tywin is
powerful she can't sit the throne as
hand of the King like Tywin she can't
hold a war council like Tywin or lead an
army like Tywin when Tywin speaks men
obey go and Cersei speaks people often
contradict her or refuse her they push
her aside because says he says she's a
woman and this deeply frustrates se she
is desperate to be the heir Tywin wanted
but she lacks the [ __ ] says he
constantly broods on the injustice of
being excluded from power on account of
her sex she recounts our when she was a
child
Cersei and her twin Jaime looked so
alike that no one could tell them apart
but they were treated so differently
Jaime was trained to fight with sword
and lance while Cersei was taught to
smile and please Jaime was heir to
Casterly Rock while Cersei was to be
married off to some Lord Jamie's fate
was glory and power while Circe's was
just marriage and childbirth Cersei
often wishes that she was born a man
because if she was a man she could rule
the realm in her own name and fight her
enemies with a sword but she says that
gods in their blind malice had given her
the feeble body of a woman says he does
use her sex to her advantage sometimes
she uses seduction to influence people
like Jamie and Lancel and oz knee but
she never really works out the kind of
subtle power that makes women like a
Leno so influential in fact Cersei hates
Elena Cole sir a disgusting old crone
and called Queen Margaery a [ __ ] and
murder sir in the show and Brienne
another powerful woman says he calls a
huge ugly shambling creature dressed in
man's mail she calls princess Elia
Martell
feeble with black eyes and a flat chest
cause lady Lysa Arryn a cow and call
scepters wrinkled [ __ ] who are probably
praying for a good raping so she not
only fails to emulate other powerful
women she hates them and is cruelly
critical of their female bodies so it is
like a self-hating woman a female
misogynist and this is one of many
contradictions in Sosa's personality she
is desperate for power and pride like
her father but she's deeply frustrated
by the limitations imposed on her as a
woman Cersei is also frustrated in her
attempts to love her mother died when
she was young and her father Tywin was
often away in King's Landing she never
had many friends there were bed maids
and companions but few lasted very long
so his closest relationship was with her
brother Jaime they'd play in Casterly
Rock as children and from a young age
they started to experiment sexually when
a maid called the matter the twins were
separated and chastised because you know
incest but the message to Cersei here
was that her most intimate relationship
was something seen as shameful and wrong
something to hide for a while there was
hope that Cersei might have a more
socially acceptable relationship because
Tywin promised that Cersei would marry
Prince Rhaegar the son of King Aerys
Targaryen for years
Cersei was happy and excited about the
prospect of marrying Rhaegar he was
beautiful and sensitive and strong a
dragon Prince so she dreamed of being
his queen but on the day says he was
promised she'd be betrothed tárrega
Aerys refused the match and Cersei
didn't get to marry the prince
she felt the heartbroken and betrayed a
memory that still hurts all these years
later so he was then told she'd marry
someone better instead but the man she
ended up with was Robert Baratheon the
man who killed Prince Rhaegar but first
says he was optimistic about this new
husband but on their wedding night when
they first had sex
Robert drunkenly called Cersei Leanna
Leanna stark was the sister of Ned and
died giving birth to Jon Snow
Robert loved Leanna and never could let
go after she died
Circe says in the show Liana was a
corpse and Circe was a living girl but
Robert loved Liana more than her so he
came to hate Robert she hated his
drinking and his infidelity and his
irresponsibility and that he'd hurt her
sometimes and so Cersei secretly
continued her relationship with Jaime
she said that she and Jamie are more
than brother and sister they are one
person in two bodies they shared a room
together and when he is in her she feels
whole the incest aspect is pretty icky
here and their relationship is messed up
in other ways too so she lies and
manipulates Jaime and cheats on Jaime
and apparently only loves him to the
extent that he looks like her so - so
she really loved Jaime or - sir see just
love Cersei
it's a dysfunctional relationship but
it's the realest love that Circe's ever
had
Jaime is therefore soci fights for
Cersei and is the father of her three
children
Cersei dreams of loving Jaime openly of
living with him as husband and wife with
their kids but because of the incest and
because of Circe's marriage to the king
she can never openly be with the person
who she loves her whole relationship
history is a series of frustrations and
denials she wants Jaime she can't have
him she wants Rhaegar she ends up with
Robert in the same way that Cersei
denied the power and pride she desires
so she's also denied love and these
frustrations feed much of her cruelty
throughout the series but there's one
more important theme to cover prophecy
when Cersei was 10 years old on the same
day she hoped to be betrothed to Prince
Rhaegar she and some friends entered the
tent of Maggy the Frog
Maggie was a witch a fortune-teller so
Cersei marched in and demanded to hear
her future Maggie granted three
questions so Cersei asked when she'd
marry Prince Rhaegar and Maggie said
never that Cersei would marry the king
Cersei asked if she'd be queen and
Maggie said Cersei will be queen until
there comes another younger and more
beautiful to cast Cersei down and take
all that she holds dear sir she asked if
she and the King would have children and
Maggie said the king
have 16 children and cersei will have
three gold shall be their crowns and
gold their shrouds Maggie said that's as
far as the show goes but in the books
maggie continued and added that when
Circe's tears have drowned her the
valonqar shall wrap his hands about her
pale white throat and choke the life
from her maggie also prophesied the
death of Sosa's friend melara so what
does this all mean well Maggie said that
Circe won't marry the prince
she'll marry the king and at first so
she thought this meant she'll marry
Prince Rhaegar after he becomes king
Rhaegar but that never happens
Rhaegar is killed and the King says he
marries is Robert Maggie is also correct
about Circe's children Robert has 16
bastards including Gondry and bara and
Maya stone while Cersei has Joffrey
Marcella and Tommen with Jaime and so
she's friend Melara does die after
maggy's prophecy Melara drowns in a well
in fact it's strongly implied that
Cersei pushed Melara killed her young
friend partly because she thought
maggy's prophecy wouldn't come true if
no one talked about it so at 10 years
old this was Circe's first murder and it
was motivated in part by fear of maggy's
prophecy Cersei is haunted by Maggie's
words for the rest of her life
Maggie accurately predicted Circe's
husband and children and the death of
Melara so says he's afraid the other
parts of the prophecy will also come
true the gold shrouds the younger more
beautiful and the Vallon quoi the gold
shroud suggests that Circe's children
will die the younger more beautiful bid
suggests that another woman will cast
Cersei down
as for the valonqar that will choke the
life from her valonqar means little
brother so so she believes that a
younger brother Tyrion will try to kill
her Maggie's prophecy threatens
everything that Cersei cares about most
her children her power and her life so
she tries desperately to avert the
prophecy she thinks Tyrion is the
valonqar so she tries to have him killed
she believes Margaery is the younger
more beautiful person so she tries to
get her killed by framing her for
adultery
she does everything she possibly can to
protect her children but it's never
enough Joffrey is murdered with poison
and dies at his own wedding
the daughter Marcella is sent to dawn by
Tyrion and is attacked in the books dead
in the show Tommen is married to
Margaery who so she feels the taking him
away from her and he ends up committing
suicide in the show he's still alive in
the books but probably not for long
so despite Circe's best efforts her
children are taken from her one by one
in golden shrouds like Maggie predicted
despite all her power
so she's unable to protect the ones she
loathes her attempts to protect herself
by killing Tyrion also failed and her
attempts to protect her power by Framing
Margaery totally backfire getting says
he locked up and humiliated the more she
finds the worse things get and in faced
Cersei spirals into fear and paranoia
desperation and delusion violence and
cruelty she sees Dwarfs in every shadow
and makes foes of friends she convinces
herself that Tyrion and Margaery are
evil schemers out to get her she
declares that she'd kill all the common
people in Westeros if that was what it
took to keep Tommen safe she's a
terrible ruler so she becomes everything
that she hated about Robert she drinks
too much and cheats on Jaime and makes
dumb decisions so he even has sex with a
woman and hurts her in bed only to
pretend the next morning that it never
happened exactly like Robert in her
desperation to protect her power and her
children and her life Circe's choices
get more extreme until she destroys
herself politically ironically it isn't
maggy's prophecy so much as Circe's fear
of the prophecy the causes are downfall
and prophecies are often like that
influence the more you try to avoid them
the more you make them true the truth of
maggy's prophecy is not what Cersei
thinks Maggie said that Cersei will be
queen until there comes another younger
and more beautiful to cast Cersei down
and take all that she holds dear
so he thinks that this is Marjorie who
is younger and arguably more beautiful
but Marjorie probably won't be the one
to cast Cersei down she's dead in the
show a more likely Queen to cast says he
down his Daenerys now sailing to take
Circe's throne
Dany is younger and said to be more
beautiful so she could perfectly fit
maggy's prophecy but there's another
cool possibility in Brienne the one who
takes Circe's dear Jaime from her
Brienne is younger than Cersei but she
isn't more beautiful in fact in the
books Brienne is very ugly so ugly that
she's called the beauty as a cruel
sarcastic joke but some fans argue the
Brienne has a metaphorical inner beauty
her heroism loyalty and kindness which
does sound a bit lame in cliche but it
could make sense for Maggy the Frog
Maggie in the show looks like a sexy
Halloween witch but Maggie in the books
is very ugly
maybe she'd want to teach Vayne young
Cersei a lesson by referring to a
woman's inner beauty also Catelyn thinks
that Brienne's eyes are beautiful and
she thinks that just after saying that
she'd like to wrap her hands around
Circe's wife's throat and choke her
almost the exact wording of Maggie's
valonqar prediction so there's
definitely some connection here between
Brienne and maggy's prophecy but
Daenerys might still be a better fit for
the person to cast soci down either way
all of Circe's efforts against Margaery
were probably pointless and only served
for Cersei to screw herself over Cersei
is also probably wrong about the
valonqar
the little brother who will kill her
it's true that Tyrion threatened Cersei
and thinks that he would like to
strangle her but there's a different
possibility that could be way more
dramatic and cool many readers believe
that the little brother who will
strangle Cersei is Jamie Jamie is
Circe's other younger brother he came
out of the womb right after Cersei did
they've been lovers almost all their
lives but while Cersei grows ever more
cruel and crazy Jaime in the books takes
a different path after losing his hand
Jaime questions his identity and starts
to change from the arrogant self
[ __ ] Kingslayer a man with [ __ ] for
honor into someone nobler someone
beginning to seek Redemption he
questions his relationship with Cersei
until finally at the end of feast he
rejects her entirely burning a letter
Cersei sent begging for help
maybe Jaime will finally realize that
his twin has become a monster maybe
it'll be up to him to end her reign of
terror
in season six of the show so she
destroys the Sept of Baelor with
wildfire and there are a lot of hints
that you'll do something similar in the
books says he's often associated with
wildfire and she knows how to use it but
in the books she probably won't just
blow up the Sept like she does in a show
in book 2 were specifically told that
wildfire is removed from the neethu Sept
so book Cersei will do something else
with wildfire something far more
dramatic so seize interest in wildfire
reminds Jaime of the Mad King Aerys
Aerys was a cruel and unpredictable
ruler and towards the end of his reign
with Robert's rebellion about to assert
him Arry said caches of wildfire placed
all over King's Landing planning to burn
down the whole city and everyone in it
leaving only ashes for Robert to rule
over he would have got away with it too
if it weren't for Jaime who killed the
Mad King and his pyromancers earning him
the name Kingslayer but thing is a lot
of Eris's wildfire is still down there
beneath King's Landing
maybe Cersei will use this wildfire to
do what Ares attempt as years ago to
destroy King's Landing and everyone in
it this could go down when Daenerys
Targaryen
or maybe Aegon in the books attacks the
city Cersei will realize that she can't
beat the invaders but she won't want to
surrender as we saw at the Battle of the
Blackwater Cersei would rather die than
be captured by enemies and with her back
against the wall and had defeated hand
all her fury and frustration will come
to boil all the slights on her pride and
power her exclusion due to her sex the
denial of her loves her fear of a
prophecy her grief or her children all
that pain will light a fire
in book 1 Cersei asks what of my wrath
Lord Stark Game of Thrones is full of
characters who fight and bleed for what
they believe in Robb Stark was to avenge
his father
Daenerys conquers for a throne Jon Snow
finds to protect the realm but Cersei
has never gotten the chance to fight so
express it as iers with action she's
always had to wait to play a role the
dutiful daughter the bride the wife she
suffered Roberts drunken groping Jaime's
jealousy Renly's mockery
she's contended with Jon Arryn Ned Stark
and Tyrion all the while promising
herself that one day it would be her
turn
but her turn never comes she never gets
a firm grasp on power she never gets to
openly love and all of her children die
so in the end maybe Cersei will finally
express her wrath her rage from all
these years in full the only way she can
she will set off heiresses wildfire to
burn down King's Landing to destroy
everyone who's ever divided her and
it'll be up to her twin Jaime to
intervene just as he killed Aerys to
save King's Landing before he'll be
forced to kill his twin Cersei he will
wrap his hands about her pale white
throat and choke the life from her one
of Jaime's hands is gold so he might
strangle her with the hand of the king
necklace the Tyrion used to kill Shaye
the links of the chain of her hands and
we know Cersei has the necklace in feast
and Jaime has thought about strangling a
woman with a necklace before and in the
season 7 trailer
Cersei stands on a part of Westeros
called the neck while Jaime stands on a
region called the fingers so the hints
are all here for Jaime to strangle
Cersei to death
Jaime will kill his lifelong lover his
other darker half in an attempt to save
the city from wildfire again but this
time he'll be too late
Cersei and Jaime came into the world
together and both of them believe that
they'll die to get
so as Jamie chokes his twin to death the
Wildfire will rise around them killing
them both leaving only the ashes and
burned-out throne room that we've seen
in visions in her desperate greed for
power and love so she will destroy her
phone and her love and herself thanks
for watching thanks to Nina Friel and a
lady Gwyn of Radio Westeros for feedback
on this script radio Westeros have a
great podcast episode about Cersei and
Jaime check it out for another
perspective on Circe's character lots of
the ideas in this video come from the
Song of Ice and Fire fan community
check out the subreddit and Westeros org
and please do sign up at audible.com
slash ASX you get a free audiobook and
you help out this channel finally thanks
to the patrons for making this video
possible including Nolan Conrad
annamaria clout ishbal bambo Jennifer
rust master 994 Andrew Beck Cheers
you